what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to pop culture explained
and today
we are launching a brand new series here
on the channel called the caught up show
and the focus here is to provide you
with everything you need to know before
you jump into a series and for our first
episode we're going to give you
everything you need to know before you
watch falcon and the winter soldier on
disney plus so if you've never seen a
marvel movie or you have seen it need to
get caught up this video is for you so
the first movie that's relevant to this
discussion is captain america the first
avenger which introduces captain america
steve rogers to the marvel cinematic
universe now steve rogers wanted to
enlist in the army and fight in world
war
ii but the army decides that he was
simply just too scrawny to be a soldier
and didn't want him now steve's best
friend bucky barnes
was accepted and doesn't list but
quickly after completing his training
bucky's promoted to the rank of sergeant
and sent to england to fight the german
army shortly thereafter bucky gets
captured by the germans and is turned
over to hydra
a terrorist organization that works
alongside the germans and wants to take
over the world now as a prisoner of
hydra bucky's experimented on by their
lead scientist arnhem zoland until he's
rescued by who else but his best buddy
in the whole wide world
steve rogers but when steve shows up
he's not the wimpy guy that buckley
remembers he's captain america now
because he was the subject of an
experiment conducted by the us military
to turn him into a super soldier he's
also powered by freedom
but after being rescued bucky returns to
the front lines and fights alongside
steve to try and take out hydra but
during a fight with hydra soldiers on a
train bucky falls and is believed to
have been dead now later captain america
sacrifices his life by flying a plane
containing weapons of mass destruction
into the ocean
instead of allowing them to detonate
later we would find out the steve was
not really dead but was just frozen in a
block of ice and after being found and
thought out he goes from super soldier
to superhero becoming one of the
founding members of the avengers and
saving the earth from an alien invasion
literally the story of captain america
is a scrawny kid gets rejected from the
military only to be experimented on by
the military and then he's frozen in ice
becomes a human popsicle gets thought
out and becomes a hero but still
steve was haunted by the trauma he
experienced as a soldier most of which
centered around
the loss of bucky in his second solo
film captain america the winter soldier
steve meets a guy named sam wilson while
jogging and it turns out sam is an air
force veteran who runs a support group
for veterans dealing with ptsd and it
turns out sam had also lost his best
friend in combat in afghanistan
so they had a lot in common and sam was
basically becoming steve's new bestie
now around this time captain america was
working with shield which was basically
a massive intelligence agency with
nearly unlimited resources that deals
with threats to the united states and
the planet but instead of using their
resources to engage in things like
humanitarian efforts
shield built weapons but as it also
turned out shield have been infiltrated
by hydra and they plan to kill a bunch
of people using shield weaponry so sam
decides he's going to help captain
america black widow and nick fury the
director of shield
stop hydra's plot and he also reveals
that during his time in the air force he
learned how to use a set of mechanical
wings to fly hence how he became known
as the falcon because the apparatus they
used to fly was called
the falcon now as they attempt to thwart
hydra's plan captain america and company
encounter an adversary named the winter
soldier who nearly kills
all of them and who also happens to be
none other than the presumed dead bucky
barnes bucky did not die when he fell
from the train due to the experiments
that hydra had done on him prior to his
rescue which greatly enhanced his
durability bucky was discovered barely
alive by a soldier from the soviet union
and was kept alive as a prisoner for
years until he became the test subject
for the soviet union's winter soldier
program which of course brought in
arnhem zola to experiment on bucky once
again because hydra was now working for
the soviet union these guys get around
now they outfit bucky with a badass
cybernetic arm to replace the one that
he lost in the fall and use electro
shock therapy to erase his memories and
he basically becomes the perfect weapon
as he's completely obedient to them when
a code phrase is spoken and he's a
skilled killer due to his training and
physiological upgrades now throughout
the cold war
the winter soldier would carry out
multiple missions for the soviets and
hydra including high profile
assassinations like jfk
and howard and maria stark iron man's
parents and was kept in a chamber
between missions that kept him from
aging
as you might expect if you're really
good at deciphering a deeper meaning
behind the movie titles captain america
the winter soldier
features an epic fight between you
guessed it captain america and the
winter soldier now during the fight
captain america rips off the mask
covering bucky barnes face
and learns his true identity but when he
says bucky's name the winter soldier
hesitates briefly before saying who the
hell is bucky but back at hydra's
headquarters following the fight
the winter soldier starts to remember
bits and pieces of his life including
his near-death experience
zola's experiments on him and he begins
to realize that he knows steve rogers
but then also becomes pissed off that
sam wilson's new bestie and the steve
rogers seems to have left him behind now
hydra wipes his mind again but during
the final showdown between the winter
soldier and captain america
steve is able to jog his memory once
again now after cap falls from a shield
helicarrier bucky saves his life by
pulling him from a river and then sets
off to try and rediscover who he truly
is now falcon becomes an avenger after
fighting alongside the team in avengers
age of ultron which
sees tony stark creating an artificial
intelligence named ultron that turns
into a villain and tries to destroy the
world but in doing so he basically wipes
out the country of sokovia now this
makes the international community
really pissed off towards the avengers
and in captain america civil war the u.n
meets to sign the sokovia accords which
will basically set up an international
panel that's designed to oversee the
superheroes now the accords are supposed
to be signed in vienna but a bomb goes
off and security tapes implicate bucky
as the bomber making him a wanted man
not only by the authorities but by
t'challa the black panther whose father
t'chaka was killed in the explosion and
who wants to kill bucky barnes now this
guy's just pissing everybody off but
captain america and falcon track down
bucky and romania and steve warns him
that he's in danger as if bucky didn't
know now bucky tells cap that the real
u.n bomber was helmut zemo who lost his
family in sokovia and wanted to take out
the avengers and by framing bucky for
the bombing he almost got his wish
captain america falcon wanda maximoff
and ant-man try to bring zemo in on
their own
while iron man black widow black panther
war machine vision and peter parker are
sent by the u.s secretary
of state thunderbolt ross to capture
them all for violating the sokovia
accords
this results in a fight between the
avengers but ultimately cap and bucky
escape
but after learning that bucky was not to
blame iron man tracks down steve and
bucky but after zemo reveals that the
winter soldier killed iron man's dad
iron man in turn attacks him can we all
also agree here that the fight between
captain america bucky and iron man was
like the greatest moment from that whole
movie it was
epic but captain america defeats iron
man and t'challa because he's a beast
and he invites bucky to take refuge in
wakanda now bucky agrees and t'challa's
sister shuri restores all of bucky's
memories and then he also receives a
pretty
awesome upgraded cybernetic arm now
bucky stays in wakanda until it's
invaded by thanos forces in avengers
infinity war because you know bucky just
can't catch a break and to make a long
story short thanos was a guy that went
across the universe searching for the
six super powerful infinity stones which
he wanted to unite and then use their
combined power to eliminate half the
life in the universe in order to restore
balance but his forces invade wakanda
because the visions being kept there and
the last stone the thanos needed the
mind stone was embedded inside of his
head
and so falcon along with pretty much
every superhero on earth
show up in wakanda and both he and bucky
battle alongside the rest of the heroes
against
thanos now their resistance proves to be
futile because thanos succeeds in
obtaining the mind stone and then he
snaps his fingers half the world's
population just starts turning to dust
including both falcon and bucky now in
the next movie avengers in-game that
movie focused on the superheroes that
were not erased from the snap
going back in time and trying to undo
the snap by gathering the infinity
stones themselves from various points in
the timeline so they can do their own
snap that'll reverse the effects of
thanos snap that's a lot of snaps and
really that's the only relevance this
has for falcon and winter soldier
because of the fact that the avengers
were successful and they basically
managed to undo the snap but steve
rogers was supposed to go back in time
to replace the stone so the time stream
wouldn't be all screwed up and for the
most part he did but instead of doing
that and then just returning to the
present day like he was supposed to he
stays in the past and lives out his
entire life that he never got to
experience with his girlfriend peggy
carter he then shows up at the end of
the film as an old man rambling about
how great things were when he was
younger and how kids have green hair
these days and it's beyond
everything and meets with bucky and
falcon now when falcon laments the fact
that he now has to live in a world with
no captain america in it captain america
hands falcon the shield now this is a
somewhat tense moment because bucky's
basically just standing there watching
his best friend
pass along his legacy to the guy that
replaced him as his best friend but he
gives sam a little nod to let him know
that he was cool with it even though it
stung a little bit so yeah that's
basically all you need to know
going into the disney plus series so now
you can dive in no matter how much of
the mcu you've seen because now you're
all basically caught up with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end thank you guys for watching we will
catch you all later
peace